[Music]  well I'm well you I feel like I get a  little piece of my best friend back  Miguel had this big touching moment in  last night's episode but for real  insight into the stars of this is us we  decided to play a little game of this is  who which of John's cast mates is most  likely to this is who is most likely to  rent out the first apartment you ever  shared decorated with twinkly lights and  half hot shower sex just because crystal  this is who is most likely to show up on  the doorstep of an ex and profess your  love I never see let's go away Justin  Hartley cuz that's half stalker half  sweet thanks Justin Hartley  this is who is most likely to be cast as  the Manny that's John where does John  where does the such a charm right now he  also told me Nancy that he was the only  person of color to audition for this  role and originally the character's name  was Mike no Miguel well it all worked  yes it does  [Music]  you